so by now both presidential candidates
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump are
preparing for the presidential debates
that are apparently going to happen I
told you a few weeks ago that Donald
Trump started sort of laying the
groundwork for potentially not debating
Hillary Clinton there's every indication
that the debates are going to happen
there debate prep tactics have been
written about and they could not be more
different and not surprisingly Donald
Trump's debate prep tactics and I hate
to even call them that because there's
not that much prep going on are
absolutely hilarious so Hillary Clinton
is reading briefing books about policy
she's reading opposition research on
Donald Trump she's working with the
debate coaches who are very experienced
she's rehearsing delivery and talking
points over and over and over again and
Donald Trump is sort of taking a little
bit of a different approach he's sort of
casually hanging out with Rudy Giuliani
mr. 9/11 as he's known to many he's
hanging out with right-wing radio host
Laura Ingraham as well as disgraced
former Fox News Chairman Roger Ailes
while eating cheeseburgers
hot dogs drinking coca-cola and instead
of focusing on policy they are testing
out zingers and insults then and this is
all according to a recent report by the
Washington Post I recently wrote an
article about read an article rather
about Tony Schwartz who ghostwrote
Donald Trump's infamous book the art of
the deal and Tony Schwartz talks about
how Donald Trump just has no attention
span and he'd be shocked if Donald Trump
had have even had even read a single
book cover-to-cover in the last 30 years
and this seems to be having an impact on
debate prep the the reported briefing
books that have been put together for
Donald Trump about Hillary Clinton have
not been read
Donald Trump has reportedly not been
doing any mock debates boasting that he
doesn't really need to and of course the
miscommunication Jason between Trump and
his campaign staff continues because
yesterday Kellyanne Conway Trump's coke
campaign manager was asked will Trump do
mock debates and she said something like
sure if we need
but maybe not but we're gonna do
everything that needs to be done but
Trump is not conventional there really
is an indication that Trump camp just
can't focus like almost like an ADHD
type of thing where if there's there's
many reports of when he's being
interviewed the reporters will mention
there was a TV on sort of in the
background and Trump couldn't even pay
attention to me because he was
distracted by the TV that's not going to
play that well in the debates I assume
that watching that that sort of ADHD
mentality when it's just two people is
different when you have seventeen people
on stage when it's Trump and Hillary
Clinton he's got to be able to focus I
think yeah he's he's like a washed-up
old beat-up prizefighter who's been
knocked around so many times that his
brain is just not quite there anymore
you know it's unclear whether it ever
was but that that's sort of a more
detailed question and then there's the
question of whether Trump really needs
to be able to go deep on any issues
because when you read that he's
preparing with zingers you would
conventionally think okay well Hillary
Clinton's going to be very well prepared
she's going to be able to go into depth
on on issues and really go
point/counterpoint
you would think that Donald Trump in a
conventional election would need to be
able to go just as deep and justify his
point of view the alternative though is
that he just does prepare these zingers
and I don't know that that's going to be
effective at convincing moderates but
Trump's own supporters would see that
and they'd probably afterwards feel that
Trump won yeah he's just gonna be for a
shouting match he's gonna try to lure
her into his his realm if you will and
get into a you know a verbal fistfight
but I think she's gonna take the high
road here she's she's well versed she's
well trained she knows what to say she's
not gonna get lured into this tactic I
agree I don't believe that Hillary
Clinton is going to fall into the the
same sort of back-and-forth that some of
the Republican contenders fell into what
will be interesting to see is how the
public perceives what is probably going
to be a very aggressive and sort of ad
hominem heavy Donald Trump in these
debates and everything we know about how
there
for these debates probably tells us a
lot about how those debates are going to
go
I am very anxiously awaiting those
debates